now anyone of a certain age remembers an
ad campaign that was used to promote
tourism in a beleaguered new york
you love the way you move
i loved your foreign accent
i love the way you put on a show
there are more ways to love new york
than there are lights on broadway
i love new york you know why of course
it's open all night
[Music]
well that was back in the 1980s and
celebrities and the tourism board came
up together and they worked to try to
save new york that was in trouble back
then
hey but if the chairman of the board
were alive today i bet he'd start
spreading a different type of news about
new york
now far left democrats at all levels of
government are responsible for cratering
a once great american city and it's
about to get a lot worse because of
something the angle warned you about at
the very start of the pandemic
as for what could come next there are
proposals for
immunity passports that will be required
for commercial flights or even go to
work
digital certificates that would certify
that individuals american citizens have
an immunity to this virus and
potentially other viruses going forward
to then facilitate travel
and work
i'm very concerned about a slippery
slope in terms of
continuing encroachments on personal
liberty
can you believe how long ago that was
and in the 14 plus months since those
comments
the only group that hasn't had its
liberties encroached upon in new york
are the looters the thugs and the gang
bangers who've been free to terrorize a
city that's now at its breaking point
but dimwit de blasio he doesn't care
his constituency consists of illegal
aliens marxist agitators teachers unions
abortion fanatics and assorted free
riders
not the proud working people who call
new york home
i want you to imagine the notion that
because
someone's vaccinated they can do all the
amazing things
that are available in this city it will
require
vaccination for workers and customers in
indoor dining in indoor fitness
facilities indoor entertainment
facilities this is going to be a
requirement the only way to patronize
these establishments indoors will be if
you're vaccinated at least one
the big bird of bloviation strikes again
now think about this you're a
restaurateur
you're one of the brave ones who decided
to keep going despite the draconian
obscene lockdowns and rules and now
they throw up this barrier to you and
your potential customer base
now for most of the past 18 months now
the city has been suffering undercover
shutdowns mandates schools were closed
criminals have had a run of the place
but
mayor de blasio wants to take the city
backward like it's still may of 2020 all
because of the delta variant
now it's just the latest excuse for once
again making life miserable for
businesses students and service industry
workers
but i'm here to tell you tonight
what de blasio is doing has zero to do
with the virus
i want you to look closely at the death
chart from covet in new york state
does this look like a crisis to you
then if you look at new york city alone
a city of 8.3 million people the seven
day average of total deaths from covert
right now
is five
on april 7 2020 alone that number was
850
we don't have a covid crisis in new york
we have a leadership crisis in new york
setting aside what we know is a gross
deprivation of liberty
which was going to be challenged in
court
this twisted new normal mandate
will be another stake in the heart of a
city struggling right now to survive
now this is the reality of life in new
york city after de blasio's reign of
terror over the last 13 months
look at it
if there's any silver lining in his
announcement today
it's this
vaccine task force will only spur more
new yorkers to pull up stakes
in tennessee right now people are
getting ready for college football
they're enjoying restaurants getting
ready to send their kids back to school
in person masculist thank you very much
in other words
they're going on with their lives
ditto with texas florida of course
coveted cases are going up but putting
everything in context the governors of
red state america know that mandates
threats intimidation restrictions
they'll eventually kill the patient
meaning
their state's economy and their
children's futures
and they also know the government's
refusal to recognize the protection that
millions and millions of americans
already have from natural immunity
cross-reactive immunity
shows that this is not about science
this is about power and about control
now biden may not understand the
dynamics at play lord knows that but
the stark contrast between life in a
free state and life in a coveted captive
state
but biden's political ventriloquist they
get it
so they sent old joe out again today to
attack desantis and abbott
president do you believe that governor
desantis and governor abbott are
personally making decisions that are
harming their own citizens
i believe the results of their decisions
are not good for their constituents
and it's clear to me
and to most the medical experts that the
decisions
being made like not allowing mass
mandates in school and like are bad
health policy
the medical experts
now as we saw happen in the spring of
2020 in the fall of
2021
the red states will once again begin to
leave the blue states that follow new
york's path behind
why would you start a new business today
in new york when you could live a normal
life in nashville
more and more americans trapped in blue
states will see that they don't have to
live this way anymore
unless but i guess you're itching to
live under
these terms skyrocketing crime murders
and shootings way up from 2019 insane
coveted rules and mandates
and the huge new entitlements that
democrats want to make permanent
back in april 2020
well the love gov he kind of let it slip
when do we get back to normal i don't
think we get back to normal
i think we get back or we we we get to a
new
normal right like we're seeing so many
facets of society right now
so
we will be at a different place
what a pull troon
if there's a shred of principle left in
the democratic party and after seeing
that guy
we'll learn more more about him later in
the show not really much of a chance of
that but
we know he's certainly going to be in a
different place
we'll have more on that government
handsy moment in a little bit later on
now until the voters in new york deliver
a resounding rebuke to the far left that
berth de blasio in cuomo
they should expect a new normal of
constant misery and any state any city
that follows their lead
will join them in a slow death via
political suicide and that's the angle
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else